even first thing in the morning the
crematoriums were burning this one in
East Beijing is reportedly just for
covert related deaths and it was busy
ambulances arriving cars carrying
coffins lined up to go in
sight across the city families gathered
to mourn and remember white is
traditionally worn at Chinese funerals
a massive covered wave is sweeping this
city but officially almost no one has
died
but while numbers can be obscured
grieving relatives cannot this party
didn't want to be identified but they
did want to talk they know covert is
killing people it's the reason they're
here
I don't believe
cheers
foreign
the corner more evidence of pressure on
this system along queue of Vans acting
as hearst's tension in the air too some
workers said they've been waiting here
for more than three hours drivers we've
spoken to in this queue say that things
are much busier than normal it's
impossible to say how many people are
dying but it seems it's more than normal
hello
I'm sorry it didn't take long for
authorities to intervene thank you
as we walked away one man tried to grab
our camera
such is the sensitivity of what's
Happening Here
and it was similar at nearly every site
we visited a heavy police presence or a
heavy effort to obstruct
but there's clearly real pressure on
this system China's hospitals are
under-resourced and there are not enough
intensive care beds at this fever
hospital we saw what appeared to be a
body wheeled out covered only in a quilt
we can't know for sure what happened but
it didn't bode well for what's going on
inside
the zero covered policy was dropped so
abruptly here many say China was simply
not prepared Beijing May well cope
better than smaller rural towns it just
isn't clear how bad things are it is
clear they'll likely get worse Helena
Smith Sky News in Beijing